whoa hey whoa hey that's a little early
don't you dance like hey that is really
early why are you here I was having a
fun time on my own okay all right I
gotta go gotta go get it go get it go
get it go get it go get it go go go
oh he get long legs Larry did long like
Larry and get long I think Larry out of
here [ __ ] off
oh [ __ ] I heard that door I heard that
door I heard that door I heard it okay
so hi welcome back everybody I had to
play through the game again because the
game got updated and they fixed a bug
which I don't think I was subject to so
I was just I was having a lot of fun by
myself figuring out the puzzle which I
already knew how to beat so anyway
welcome back to mere layers um in this
episode we are going to be figuring out
the mystery of the tape which hopefully
we come over here it won't just lead to
our imminent demise and uh pretty sure I
probably yeah I still got father so I
still had box for what 12 minutes oh
that's right so here's the secret to
this it gives me a letter and I'm gonna
write this down because I've got a
notepad right here it gives me D and
then it gives me a number the 12 minutes
podcast and I learned this off because
there's that big Facebook group oh and
also I I'm back to my original hair
color this is a bad place to be talking
about this so if you look at the clocks
there is 12:45 there's 3 o'clock there's
um there's 233 and Oh
and then there's there's a 4-12
so there's 412 233 412 233 3 o'clock and
then 12:45 and then there's this D so D
of is a lot to remember our [ __ ] I
[ __ ] you're out there quickly oh hey
okay so anyway [ __ ] so ah what the [ __ ]
was I trying to remember that's right
okay so we got D 12 which relates to
12:45 and then we've got other letters
that come in other tapes that go in to
the statue input which I've got right
here [ __ ] I am hearing those step East
epi sounds everywhere I go so yeah bit
of a rushed entry into this game I don't
know why every time I play this game
it's always like a frantic sprint to get
to the done I've gone to that page and
I've downloaded all of the tapes these
are every one of the tapes ah and I'm
gonna put them in with a statue input
and even though I've already got father
here I bet I'm gonna get a duplicate
copy of it or maybe I won't I'm not sure
but um here they are just like that I
give we got dad we've got father
we've got dad father again so I didn't
get a duplicate father not that I needed
it I'll put it over in the father column
and then we got daddy and we've got [ __ ]
we've got a tape labeled [ __ ] right
dare stop dinging me I'm not in the mood
okay so one thing I forgot to also write
is um the other times it was 3 o'clock
for 12 and then 2 33 32 33 I can't
remember specifically um now that I'm
looking at this I'm thinking I'm
thinking this actually might be this
time so what I got to do is I gotta take
these tapes into the game individually
and then look for the letter and listen
for the time that they say cuz they will
say a time they pop that bad boy in
there hello everybody welcome to classic
video here for the clock broadcast to 3
o'clock 3 o'clock e e is 3 o'clock so
I'm gonna take this tape back with me
hey hey yeah yeah look it's true yeah ok
so that was three o'clock
that was three o'clock so that's good
put that there so that means e E is 3 e
this is e e is 3 o'clock then I've got
the Daddy tape
he is also dad b45 be 45 be 45 be 45 can
I go through hi okay that was a bit of a
delay I didn't like that be 45 so be B
is 12:45 okay so and then [ __ ] [ __ ]
must be the last one which is 32 so G 33
so I've got that so now I've got all the
pieces all tell us [ __ ] weird it was
like blacked over if I go over there too
much am I not gonna be able to return
probably okay so we've got D 412 e 3
o'clock B 12:45 and G 2 33 so because
because they were calling out the
minutes and if I'm not mistaken hang on
let me get this where I can see it we're
gonna see it like right there ok so
right there okay so if I'm not mistaken
I'm risking something by going in here
I've been going in here a lot very
quickly but over here you've got okay it
goes up to 8 so it can't be 12 so it's
got to be either some summation of all
the other numbers look it's a it's
either a summation of the other
numbers or that [ __ ] that's quick oh
that's really quick huh
hi hi how are you let me get a look at
you I don't want to get a look at you
yeah hey I don't like that [ __ ] oh
well that's weird
Oh what are you doing oh I don't like
that oh I don't like that
oh [ __ ] where's he going yi hey pal [ __ ]
rip Oh God did he lose me oh I think he
lost me
maybe if I crawl
I'll stealthy like he'll never find me
he'll never find
oh boy oh boy oh boy he'll never find me
so I have to get so I'm assuming it's d4
III b12 and then g2 is he gone
I think he's gone he's probably not gone
deep it either way I think I think he
think I think it's be probably 3 d 4 III
then g2 nope that was not it's okay so
these are the definites it's definitely
III definitely d4 well maybe not know
coz 45 adds up to 9 so that wouldn't be
it so it's got to be a B number so I'm
just gonna start a [ __ ] G 2 e 3 d 4 I
mean there's only so many combinations
to be by looking what holy [ __ ]
the fack the FAC back was the [ __ ] he
was silent man I don't know why my voice
has not recovered yet my voice has
absolutely not been able to recover no
matter what I do
oh man I just keep playing these horror
games it just thrashes him over and over
again am i even back in the same okay I
am in back in the same spot at least
okay so it was G to die maybe too many
failed attempts is just death don't like
it III [ __ ] goddamn it not that not
that [ __ ] not that [ __ ] us oh okay
all right
okay oh god I hear him oh hey hello oh
it's it's the arm Oh Ivan call you
angular arm Angela oh we're gonna go on
an adventure angular or m'angil ah oh hi
you're getting a little too close to my
face angular arm Angela oh god he's out
there he doesn't like me very much he
doesn't like me much at all hello hi I
got southern you're welcome you're
welcome
oh you're welcome okay all right whoa oh
man so I'm gonna find out what the next
puzzle because I haven't looked into
this so I don't exactly know what hello
f7 7f okay that's good
I don't know what that means okay so I
hello
21 you see okay so we've got books with
codes so that means there's got to be
someplace to put in the codes maybe just
back in the computer
no books books books books books books
books backs
give me bugs anybody got some Bay Oaks
so this is for oh hello yeah I don't
like that eight fzk all right
so this is the first time that it's
given me more than one thing in my world
well well that's different
well that that's different okay have I
seen that I don't think I've seen that
well I don't think I've been in this
bathroom block [ __ ] [ __ ] oh my god I
think I think what it is yeah I think
what it is he'll kill you if you spend
too long in that world no matter what
you can elude him but he'll get shot oh
he's gonna get you he's gonna get you
good
okay so I can only assume that I can
only assume that those go in somewhere
so it was f7 7f maybe if I put that in
f77 half nope that ain't it okay let me
see if there's more because there's been
four things in every one I gotta imagine
that there's four books so I got three
I'll write down all the codes in a bit
oh here we go
q eb k bad idea is a bad idea
21 you see always a bad idea 21 you see
oh there's a bad idea oh is bad idea f7
7f okay they have numbers on the sides
oh boy okay I do they have numbers on
the side I can barely make it off
[ __ ] [ __ ] hey I thought I heard
something QE I see something on the side
but I can't tell what it is
this definitely hasn't been there three
seconds what does that mean
hey [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] hey hey [ __ ] hey
[ __ ] you [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] it so I'm at
Englishman
okay so eight fzk maybe if I put them
through the statue they're gonna tell me
something so I'm gonna put this one
through the statue and see what it means
so if I put this here yeah boo okay
transfer to your world I go to the I go
to the output folder death Oh death oh
good old death okay so I'm gonna copy
this I'm gonna put this in the books I'm
gonna create a books folder I got death
taught me roar which is good think so at
least I'll have hard copies of all of
these god I can't go back through huh I
want to go back please let me go back
please please let me go back q eb k
maybe maybe i put them in in capital
letters q eb k so let me try lowercase Q
ah f7 7f uh oh wait is that Morse code
hang on
doo doo doo de doo darude-sandstorm dude
it it it it so maybe that last one's
long but I'm gonna assume q eb k okay so
if i put this over here q eb k is uh its
dot dot dot long dead - dah dah dot okay
so is yeah let me let me take out this
first one don't it did this wooden was
dead it was this one
yeah that's five that's darude-sandstorm
Dada Dada Dada dot okay
Dada Dada okay then we got twenty-one
you see that was that was five short
that was definitely five short dead a
tete-a-tete and then the last one is oh
wait no the F seven seven F was dead -
da Dada at so q FZ k
f ck that was it that was the one in q f
ck a f ck f ck not Q 8 so 8 f ck so I
didn't need to bring them over here it's
same book position so maybe I gotta like
put them back so 8 FZ k naught Q 8 8 8 f
ck yeah long short short short ok so I
got these coordinates so 8 f ck that's
the first one I'm gonna go for did it I
did it okay then I'm gonna get this
where I can see it again oh no right
there so I'm gonna take 8 f ck and so I
gotta I gotta find like a bookshelf no
stuff over here
no okay not there I don't see oh hey
back this chest oh oh oh I gotcha I
gotcha
oh I gotcha okay so [ __ ] ah
did the duh duh duh [ __ ] I don't know
what this means to this ship [ __ ] okay
alright alright for a [ __ ] are ya [ __ ]
are you the [ __ ] are you hey where the
[ __ ] are you
okay so what I've got is it got a puzzle
and I've got all the pieces but what I
don't have is time so unfortunately I'm
gonna figure this out in the next
episode but I've got everything that I
need right here in front of me so I
should be able to do this easily I've
got all the information I've got all the
books I just need to put them on the
bookshelf and open the box so I'm gonna
get to that very quickly so thank you
everybody so much for watching let me
know what you think down the comments
below let me know how far you've gotten
and if you want to go over to that
Facebook group and you figured things
out for yourself help other people there
are other people that are currently lost
right now I'm not lost but I'm getting
there so either way help them out lend a
hand and we'll get this mystery solved
so thank you everybody so much for
watching and as always I will see you in
the next video bye bye